according to fillian who has said his
time on Firefly was the best job he ever
had there's no real need for any more
adventures in a 2015 interview with
Esquire he admitted we were able to have
a nice kind of final goodbye we had
closure which is more than a lot of
people with canceled shows can say
nevertheless in his 2022 interview with
Michael rosenbom dillian revealed that
he'd jump at the chance to play M
Reynolds once more on the flip side tudk
told Esquire that quote it's going to
take a little time saying that he likes
the idea of it in another 10 years or so
he believes that Clint eastwoods West
epic Unforgiven is the best model to
follow just with filan's character at
the center